Thank you for finishing your assignments. I will
be providing feedback on the discussion forums periodically.
Okay, so I now want to talk about how
Python knows about this thing called the turtle.
Well, inside the Python Standard Library, there is this file called
turtle. Turtle with a lowercase t, and inside that
file is something new. And that something new is called a class.
A class Turtle with an upper case T. Now,
this is a little different than what we have
seen thus far. What we have done thus far
is some sort of file, like web browser, dot some
sort of function, like open. But we haven't seen
this thing called a class. Which begs the question, what
is a class? For now you can think of
a class as a neatly packaged box, that puts things
together really well. And it allows us to
write code like turtle.Turtle, with these strange looking
brackets. As if we were calling a function. In fact, when we do it on this piece
of code, we are in fact calling a
function, a function called init which is defined inside
the class Turtle. Init stands for initialize, and
what it does is it creates space in memory
for a new instance or a new object of the class Turtle. This instance we called
brad. Brad can now access all of the rest of the methods that are inside
class Turtle. Like forward, and right. Forward makes
brad turn forward, and right makes brad turn
to the right. Don't take my word for
it, let's look for them in the documentation.